always cool you know he just he spoke my
name without really explaining what he
meant that's literally that stems from a
victim mindset like when you when you
think you're a victim you always want to
make things public oh you actually
always feel like you're wrong because if
you think about it really and truly red
pill in itself is good but the people
that majority of the people that I read
peeled going the wrong I don't know if I
don't know if I'm putting this correctly
but I think majority of people that are
red people are going down the wrong path
even after being read so you get red
pilled and you still have a victim
mentality